كانت تستوقفني بعض المشاهد هنا وهناك كانت
تتبعثر في زوايا ذاكرتي بعض المصطلحات اعي
نصفها والنصف الاخر لا اعيه كان يطرق
ابوابنا في غير وقت الزياره اناس لا افهم
سلوكهم ولا لباسهم ولا حتى لغتهم اسالوا
من هم احاولوا معرفه سبب وجودهم وما لهم
عند ابي واعمامي يوما بعد يوم نتقدم في
اعمارنا نبدا نعيما حولنا
قادرين على الكتابه والقراءه
وامتلكنا مهاره التمييز والتفسير الى حد
ما لما حولنا لم نكن نعرف ماذا يعني
التحدي ولو تحدي الذات ومع ذلك مارست
التحدي مع نصف جهلي معناه فشاربت في
مسابقه عالميه اعلنت عنها مدرستي حاولت
تحديد ما املك من امكانيات وما تحتاجه هذه
المسابقه فكانت اول عباره وضعتها الاراده
تتحدى الصاد وكان هدفي هو الفوز والنجاح
فلم لمن يدي ورتبت ما استطعت من افكاري
ورسمت خطواتي خطوه خطوه
اتجاوز واحده واستجمع قواي نحو التي تليها
وجدت معلماتي حولي بعضهن واثق من نجاحي
والبعض الاخر بين البيت اهلي وعائلتي ايضا
لم يصلوا الى ان اخر اهدافي قد يكون بين
يديك كما ان في خطوات الاولى لم تكن
نظراتي نحو خط النهايه واضحه انتقلت من
مرحله تجميع قدراتي نحو التقدم العملي
فيها
فتجاوزت اول مراحل مسابقتي بنجاح وكان اول
نجاح بمثابه الطاقه بمثابه الطاقه التي لم
اكن اعيها في نفسي ولكني وجدتها
وازدادت ثقتي بنفسي وهدفي بات اكثر وضوحا
ومسار خطاي ياخذ وضعه الموصل للنجاح
وبينما انا اعلو على نصف درجات سلم التفوق
حدث ما لم اكن اتوقع
فعاد الزائر الغريب مره اخرى ولكن هذه
المره ليس بجسده ولم يترك باب بيتي هذه
المره
امتدت رصاصه حقده نحو جوريه بيتنا التي
كنا نقترب منها حين نحتاج الى القليل من
الضحك نشتم ريحها حين نحتاج الى القليل من
البسمه
فاقتلعت يد الغدر تلك الورده المتمثله في
عم الشهيد عريف جرادات رحمه الله
فارسلته الى الموت الذي لم اكن اعرف معناه
ولا اثاره
فوقفت حيث انا على نصف سلم النجاح فلم تكن
قدمي تمتلك من القوه ما تجعلها تعلو درجه
اخرى
وقفت
وقفت وكدت من اختلال توازني ان اعود الى
حيث الخطوه الاولى
ولكن لحسن ظني وجدت من السواعد التي حولي
ابي وامي التي امتدت ليس لاتقدم
التي امتدت ليس لاتقدم بل كحد ادنى كي
ابقى حيث انا الى ان اعيد ترتيب نفسي
واعيد ترتيب ما بعثرته تلك الرصاصه وذاك
الغياب وتلك الدمعه وذاك الوداع كي اعي ان
الحياه لا يمكنها ان تتوقف رغم كل
الصعوبات
رفعت قدمي كي اخطو خطوه اخرى للاعلى
لكنها توقفت في الهوايا ايضا بين درجه
الثبات ودرجه التي تعلوها حيث ارتد الحزن
الى القلب وعاد الدمع الى العين وزارنا
الموت مره اخرى زارنا حاملا بين يديه جدي
الذي مات قهرا على فلدت كبده الشهيد
ولكن هذه المره لم احتاج من الوقت كوقت
الانتظار الذي عشته في المره الاولى لانني
اصبحت اكثر قوه وامانا وعزيمه بان هزيمه
الحزن تكمن في النجاح
بالعكس اصبحت خطاي اكثر ثقه وقدراتي اكثر
قوه وعزيمه اكثر تصميما للوصول الى هدفي
اولا لكي يعيد البسمه لي ولمن حولي ولكي
اوصل رساله مره اخرى الى الزائر الغريب
باننا نستحق الحياه
وسنمضي اليها ما استطعنا سبيلا سنمضي
اليها ما استطعنا سبيلا
[تصفيق]
درست
حللت سهرت وعملت حتى وصلت الى نقطه
النهايه في سباقي مع ذاتي وكانت لحظات لا
يمكن وصفها حين وصلنا للمرحله الاخيره يوم
اجتمع كل المتسابقين من كل انحاء الوطن كي
يحمل احدا فينا شاره الفوز وكاس النجاح
وضعت قلبي جانبا واغمضت عيناي ووضعت اصابع
كفي على اذني الى حين اعلان النتائج لم
اكن قادره على احتمال خساره جديده
وفي ظل لحظات الانتظار ايقظني من كان
بجانبي مبتسمين والفرحه في عيونهم لا توصف
فاخبرني الجميع اني نلت كاس المسابقه
بعد ثلاث سنوات متتاليه من المشاركه
والعزيمه والاصرار للوصول الى الهدف
عدت واهلي ومعلمي الى بيتي احملوا فوزي
وفرحتي ونجاحي وبسمه تتوزع على كل من
يعرفني وعاد الفرح يطرق باب بيتنا وحارتنا
مره اخرى وكان في الانتظار احبتي من احبني
وانتظر نصري وتعالت صوت زغاريد امي ونساء
اهلي وقاهرنا الظلام واخرجت اقاربي من
سفينه الحزن التي توقفت في بحر الدموع الى
بر السعاده والفرح والاعتزاز تحول يومي
الى ضوء ليله ونهاره استبدلت دمعه فرحتي
بدمعه حزني وبدات الاحلام تراودني في صحوي
وفي منامي اسال نفسي ومن حولي ماذا بعد
وقفت بين جمع المهنئين اخاطبهم الا تفرطوا
في افراحكم وابكوا شيئا منها لما هو قادم
الان بدايه والقادم اجمل لم لم اغراضي
رتبت ما توقعت اني احتاجه وضعت بعض
الاوراق التي تناثرت على مدار سنين سباقي
على رفوف الانتظار واخذت منها ما يلزم
للاتي
اعدت تجديد بطاقتي وطاقتي وجواز سفري
واوراقي وشهادات نجاحي وتفوقي كي ترافقني
في السباق الاهم والفوز الذي بدات اخطط له
وارسم حدود خارطته وكنت على ثقه كامله
انني ساعود الى وطني واهلي وابي وامي
ولروحي جدي وعمي بكاس الانتصار العظيم
ودعت صديقاتي واقمت حفلات وداع لاقاربي
فقطار النجاح بات ينتظرني ان اجلس في احد
عرباته فهو على وشك الانطلاق وسكته جاهزه
وقبطانه ينادي على راكبيه كنت انتظر
تاشيره السفر وتذكره العبور الى مستقبلي
الذي بدات ملامحه كحد ادنى بالنسبه لي
تتضح وبدات في ثنايا احلامي اتخيل القادم
ارسم بعض الصعوبات واضعوا خططا لتجاوزها
وضعت اخرا نقاط على حروف روايه الاخيره
اهتديت الى عنوانها واهدائها وفصولها وكل
اوراقي وامتعتي مركونه على عتبه البيت في
انتظار صافره الانطلاق لم يتبقى سوى
تاشيره العبور
يرن هاتفي
ستكون جاهزه
ساعيد التاكد من اغراضي يرن هاتفي مره
اخرى هناك اشكاليات في الموافقه عليها
وصدورها لكن نعمل على تجاوزها
تنتابني فترات صمت طويله احاول ان انام
تلك الليله واهلي واحبتي احدهم يودعني
لانه ذاهب غدا الى عمله والاخر يراسلني
على مواقع التواصل يتمنى لي التوفيق
وانا
وانا في مرحله التيه
وضعت راسي على وسادتي ابقيت هاتفي في
شاحنه بانتظار الاتصال الاخير لم انا
ولكني لم اظهر لمن حولي رن هاتفي
وكانت المكالمه الاكثر وجعا وبصوت خافت
قيل لي لا مجال للسفر ولا مكان لك بين
المتسابقين فالزائر الغريب لم يرق له
نجاحك الاول فكيف يمنحك فرصه النجاح
الاخير
وضعت هاتفي
لم ابكي ولا ادري لماذا عدت الى غرفتي
ونمت وكان النوم الاطول لي منذ زمن
انطلق القطار
وهاتفني راكبوا حدثوني عن مقعد الفارغ
هناك
فاسمك مكتوب وصورتك حاضره فاين انت
قلت لهم انا هنا
قمت من نومي وصرخت انا مازلت طفله رغم
قوتي مالي ومالك يا زائرون الغريب ما بيني
وبينك لكي تمنعني من الحلم وتقف بيني وبين
مستقبلي اخذت منا ما ليس لك واكثر فماذا
تريد اكثر
صرخت وعدت الى نومي اجد نفسي لا اقوى على
الحديث مع الاخرين اغلقت هاتفي وباب غرفتي
وصمت عن الحديث وعن التفاعل مع الاخرين
حاول البعض مواساه وتهدئاتي
اسمع ما يقولون ولا اعي معاني كلماتهم ولا
يتردد على مسامع سوى انتهت احلامي
استمر حالي على هذه الحال اياما كانت
قليله العدد لكنها والله طويله الساعه
بعد ايام
بدات رحلتي في الثانويه العامه
وبفضل وتوفيق من ربي ورضا من والدي تمكنت
من اجتياز الرحله باقل الخسائر
وبعد بضعه ايام وقفت امام نفسي على المراه
اتساءل اين ذهبت يافا اين ذهبت يافا
القويه والطموحه واين ذهبت احلامها
ثم قمت
ونفضت الغبار عن كتبي واوراقي وابحاثي
اعدت ترتيب اولوياتي باحثه عن مسار جديد
لرحله نجاح جديده
عشت مرحله الصراع مع الذات هل اتى من جديد
كيف ابدا واين ابدا
فكرت كثيرا واخذت اراء من اثق بهم وقررت
ان تكون بدايه الجديده في جامعه فلسطين
وضعت صوبعيني اهدافا كثيره وحددت مسار
دراستي ورفعت شاره الانطلاق نحو مسيره
جديده وبلطف من الله هيا لي الاسباب التي
ستساعدني على الانطلاق التقيت عميد كليه
القبول والتسجيل في الجامعه وهو احد
محكممي مشروعي في المسابقه العالميه
وهنا كانت المفاجاه تنتظر يافا
قام بتشبيك فورا مع حاضنه اعمال جامعه
هوليتكنك فلسطين
وكانوا قد اعلنوا عن مسابقه تدعى
للمشاريع الرياديه ورغم صغر سني الا انني
تمكنت من المشاركه وكنت اصغر المشاركين
فيها وجدت في هذه المسابقه التحدي الاكبر
لنفسي
سهرت وتعبت وبذلت جهدا كبيرا حتى وصلت الى
اولى محطات النجاح في الجامع وكنت احد
الفائزين الاربعه في هذه المصادقه
صدقا كانت الفرصه التي كنت ابحث عنها لكي
اجدد طاقتي واستعيد ثقتي بنفسي واطور من
مهاراتي واكون شبكه علاقات افخر بها عدت
الى نفس المراه وقلت لها نعم هذه هي يافا
يوما بعد يوم كنت اجد ذاتي بين قاعات
جامعاتي وارتسمت لي عائله جديده من اساتذه
وزملائي وبدات انتقل
من نجاح الى نجاح ومن تفوق الى تفوق وقررت
ان ابحر في عالم الرياده اكثر وكنت اشارك
في كل التدريبات مع الحاضنه ومع غيرها
واذهب الى كل الفرص التي تساعدني على
تطوير ذاتي ومهاراتي قمت بعمل ورشه عمل في
قريتي شاركت في عده مؤتمرات الكترونيه
وجاهيه تعنى بالشباب والرياده كما شاركت
في تدريب مع المعهد الكويتي
في مجال المشاريع الصغيره كما كنت الفائزه
الوحيده من الضفه الغربيه في تحدي
الجامعات على مستوى الوطن بجناحيه الضفه
وغزه والكثير الكثير من الفرص التي اعتز
بها وكان اخرها هكذا الحوسبه الكميه الذي
حصدت فيه مركزا اولا على مستوى فلسطين
وانا الان استعد للمنافسه على مستوى
العالم باذن الله في الاشهر القادمه كما
اسمحوا لي ان اعبر عن فخري كوني سفيره
رياضيه لهذه الحاضنه ولهذه الجامعه وسفيره
علاقات عامه واحد المسؤولين في مجموعه
جمهوريه البلو تكنيك على الفيسبوك التي
تساعد وتعنى بخدمه الطالب ولا انسى ايضا
انني عضو علاقات عامه في اكاديميه البرمجه
في الجامعه واحد اعضاء اكاديميه امتياز
طلبه الحاسوب
هانا اليوم اسير على درب الانجازات واطمح
مجددا وتمتد يدي نحو ما هو ابعد من مداها
لكي تلامس وترفع كاس الفوز من جديد ولا
زلت اجد في نفسي بدايه عالمي الذي ابحث
عنه ولم اتوقع ولن اتوقف ما منحنى ما
منحني الله عمرا الا وكاس حلمي بين يديك
وانا على ثقه بانه لي صمم لي وسيكون لي
وساهديه لروحي من رحلوا ولقلوب من كانوا
معي ساهديه الى ابي وامي نور عيناي من
سالوا في طريق نجاح قبلي من منحوني كل ما
احتاج لكي اكون انا الى اخواتي تفاحات
قلبي كرمل ومجدل وبيسان ورتا وشام وايلياء
ووطن
ساهديه الى عائلتي وبلدتي ساهديه الى
اساتذتي من كان لهم دورا في نجاحاتي
ساهديه الى زملائي ورفاقي ساهديه الى
بلدتي ووطني الى كل من اسهم بالوصول الى
هذا النجاح واخيرا وليس اخرا اود ان اقول
ان هذه التحديات والانجازات لم يكن وراءها
اله كان وراءها انسان يضحك ويبكي يفرح
ويحزن كان امامي طريقا اما ان العب دور
الضحيه واتخلى عن احلامي لانني فتاه
فلسطينيه وتحت احتلال او ان اختار طريقه
تحدي
المليء بالصعوبات فاخترت الطريقه الثانيه
الحياه شغلتين يا بتشوف الهدف يا بتشوف
المعيقات وانا دايما بحكي شوف الهدف وتوكل
على الله